[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai trouvé très intéressant qu'on nous
implique dans la construction du
quartier des savoirs parce que c'est un
quartier qu'on va utiliser qu'on
aimerait pouvoir aller voir
régulièrement
donc je trouve ça bien de demander aux
gens qui habitent de voir ce qui manque
pour pouvoir étayer la demande qui
revient souvent c'est garder la verdure
voilà ce qui vraiment plein oui encore
toi c'est d'avoir un poumon vert d'avoir
de la verdure de pouvoir circuler en
vélo à pied ya vraiment cette volonté de
on est en ville mais à la fois on veut
de pouvoir vivre un peu comme à la
campagne tournée en est à trois
structures de la ville
j'ai découvert ce quartier on en parle
depuis des années de la flèche thales et
te dire que de l'avoir découverte comme
ça ça va impressionner et un enjeu
important pour retrouver un recréer un
quartier avec des équilibres diversifier
les commerces des services accueillir
des écoles peut-être à marcher
énormément de choses intéressantes
je pense que c'est une très très bonne
démarche est de donner la parole aux
citoyens surtout et est donc aux
résidents pour voir un peu ce qu'ils
pensent du projet et surtout leurs
attentes leurs réflexions de projet doit
pas se résumer à regarder autour de ça
les petites chapelles il faut aussi
prévoir les impacts sur l'ensemble sur
l'agglomération
la gare est un pôle très attractif qui
va servir d'aimant et qui va donc
attirer toute la population de saclay de
l'yvette et de la haie de la lièvre
voire de ses voisins mais aussi la
population du nord et aussi les gens de
montigny 2 millions pour tout sauf
qui se partageront entre les 2 gr
l'implication des habitants je trouve
que c'est une bonne idée ça permet aussi
de voir comment les gens vivent aux
alentours ce qui leur manque ce qui leur
paraît intéressant pour mon genre de
projet avec une certaine diversité de
des habitants 40 d'âge
c'est ça aussi ouvert aux gens des
communes voisines c'est aussi un
important c'est une bonne idée de
démocratie participative avec les idées
que j'ai pu émettre
on aura peut-être une petite
satisfaction se disant que ça c'est une
ma petite idée elle a été retenue pour
maintenant l'amélioration et la création
de ce nouveau quartier
[Musique]